do you actually know how to make
creative for pinterest versus linkedin
versus youtube shorts versus tick tock
and that is creative strategy and
platform strategy and understanding
attention and culture at a phd level and
yet most people just mail in they're
social and they care about all this
other stuff their brand and billboards
and remnant tv and i'm just watching
this landscape and so one we need to
actually get into the creative business
and make things that people want to
watch two we need to make it for many
different consumer segmentations this is
not television where you make a piece of
vanilla and you hope that everybody on
earth wants it this is baskin robbins
and we need to make a lot of different
flavors and go up and then see the
common ground and then understand what
our brand stands for based on 37
different consumer segmentations of
relevance once you can understand the
upside down model of how brands are
built because the internet now rules not
the television then you can really start
to understand what to do